Let's just assume we're out in the
streets and I become aware with this
suspect has committed a crime of
shoplifting,
not the worst crime in the world,
but the shopkeeper says,
Hey,
that guy just salt stole 10 bags to
sequent the odor it and I can smell the
guy from a distance.
And though,
and now I know why he needs the secret,
the old one,
but even paid for it,
right?
So now I'm basically doing my psychic
interpretation of them and I realize
he's a real nebbish.
She's a real schlub.
He's like not going to physically
resist,
probably does yoga.
You know,
he's probably very new agey.
He probably balances crystals and
watches Oprah.
So I know I got this guy in control,
I'm the sadist,
he's Damascus.
He probably wants me to put a ball gag
in his mouth and whip him,
but it's not that kind of submission.
So what I do is I refer to the ancient
code of Magna Carta and as if I was to
show up,
I'm loving him.
I say you,
I suspect who has committed a crime,
you are in violation of the penal code.
So therefore I want you to wait for the
police for five o copper squat.
Sit down and sit down now.
So he understands I'm in charge and he
likes to be submissive.
Maybe he's getting his jollies off while
his weight problem is I'm calling nine
one one and the cops,
uh,
Bustin donuts,
right that pound in donuts waiting for
the fresh buttermilk toys to come out of
the Dunkin donuts of it will be waiting
a month of Sundays.
But he's enjoying being submissive.
So Hey,
no pain,
no strain.
Right?
Can I have reason to believe I've seen
or it's been brought to my attention
that this Cretin with chromosome damage
has snatched the chain off somebody's
neck and it's not a little monster.
Cause I could tell he hasn't been to a
lady.
God got conscious.
He's not weaken soft in that regard,
but he's ready to put up a fight.
I could tell there's a certain
intensity.
Once again,
I'm using my psychic parameters now in a
general self defense costs.
They would say,
look for his solar plexus.
I can't even find his girdle.
Nevermind.
He's Goin to.
So I'm not even looking for a solar
plexus.
They say,
Oh,
you want to hit a boom,
right in his Adam's apple,
it drive his Adam's apple or the bridge
of his nose and he'll know not to go.
You think that will be wrassling around
bridge of the nose?
Adam's apple as if I'm studying biology
to prepare to become doctor md.
No.
What I do is it's for myself or if they
are a number of others.
The weakest point of any person is any
cabs I gotta make his kneecap sing and
ring and in fact his instep,
which just walden,
five pounds of questioning,
Bam.
It's guy who's going to be doing a
hopalong cassidy and then as he's
pulling the hopalong cassidy,
I'm going to take his head right like
this.
Bam,
like down on to which knee that will be
goes.
He will be in the primal fetal position.
I really won't have to do much if I have
a pair of handcuffs on or if I have a
belt that just tie them up to a
stationary object can wait for the
police.
Right now.
My problem is if this massive swelling
and I can't find this steak or a piece
and to put the swelling down,
I could end up going to jail myself
because I don't know,
right to go over the top.
Use excessive physical force.
Even though he is committed a crime.
I have no special powers and privileges.
I am not a police officer,
so I have to make sure that whatever for
I use,
particularly in this fact that he's just
snatched the chain.
He hasn't threatened to anybody's life
that if I'm violating him physically,
he may go to jail,
get charged for change snatching.
But I may be charged with assault and
battery cause a copper may turn around
after munching on the doughnuts and say
it,
you know,
you have the right to Keller charge,
have him arrested.
And then once he hooks up with a lawyer,
a b lawyer that they assigned in court,
he goes,
hey,
do you ever think of,
so in the Guardian Angels,
I could get a third of the action.
No,
retain his sign on the dotted line.
So you've gotta be very cautious under
column b,
Rules and regulations.
Now,
this guy,
enemy of society is intent on becoming a
modern day street warrior,
a.
K,
a shy,
he a k a suicide kamikaze maniac because
he knows he's going to j a I l and he
wants to go out in a blaze of glory.
He could have a bat,
he could have a stick,
he could have a chain,
he could have a ship pool.
He wants to stick me right underneath
the ribs,
which would cause me to bleed to death
before I even hit the ground.
Or he might have a tool in a gun.
I've got to make an instantaneous
decision to move towards the guy because
if I move away from the guy,
there's a good chance I'm going to get
hit anyway.
And in the process of falling back,
I lose the aggressiveness.
He's on the attack,
him on the defensive.
Very difficult for me to get control of
him.
So what I want to be able to do is get
them into a position where I can spin
them around and then
no,
by moving one way or the other one I met
at that point of Ireland had a guardian
angel to the three.
We can take them down lickety split and
then by myself I can rest more.
When they at the restaurant
now you see in the process of waking is
back.
You might say,
oh,
dastardly how over the top how
neanderthal of you,
but if this guy has a weapon and he's
just committed a crime with a weapon,
guess what?
The judge is going to actually like an
accordion giving me more leeway than
they would a police officer who should
know better,
who should be in control of his mental
and physical faculties,
who should be able to immediately get on
his walkie talkie and some in other
police officers to give them some
backup.
If I'm on my own,
I have to use whatever force is
necessary to protect myself,
to protect other victims,
to protect maybe in this instance even
himself because if he has a weapon,
you may end up doing harm to himself if
he misuses it.
I can't tell you how many times I've
shown up at a location where the guy
who,
uh,
let's face it,
couldn't connect all the dots.
Even if you tried for a month of
Sundays,
ended up shooting himself cause they
keep the gun there in the belt and they
keep it write me at the their thigh and
they ended up shooting themselves so
many times because they already have it
on the trigger.
It's already triggered the fire that
round that's in the barrel of the gun.
They don't even have the safety on it.
So they ended up shooting themselves as
they're trying to run away from you.
So you were actually doing him a solid,
even though temporarily he's going to
have a lot of strain and pain and oohs
and Aahs.
They'll worry about it.
He'll still live.
He's not going to be room temperature
and you won't be sued.
Now,
this is not something you should be
treated,
your own house.
Just something that you have to
practice.
Practice,
practice,
like as if you were playing rock and
off,
had a concerto on a baby.
Grand Piano.
Trust me,
I've done this many,
many times,
so I wouldn't suggest it as a sort of a
new jacket.
First Time citizen arrest are out there
a do gooder,
who all of a sudden wants to earn the
Congressional Medal of honor.
Right.